قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان لا خلاف بين السودان
واثيوبيا حول سد النهضه وان البلدين
متوافقين ومتفقين حول كافه قضايا السد
واوضح البرهان خلال الجلسه او جلسه
المباحثات المشتركه مع رئيس الوزراء
لاثيوبي ابي احمد ان الوثائق والاليات
الفنيه والحوار تمثل مرجعيه الاساسيه فيما
يتعلق بقضيه حدود بين البلدين من جانبه
قال ابي احمد ان سد النهضه لن يسبب اي ضرر
للسودان وسيعود عليه بالمنفعه في مجال
الكهرباء مبينا قضيه الحدود بين البلدين
بانها قديمه ويجب الرجوع الى الوثائق لحل
لها داعيا السودان لتقديم اثيوبيا للعرب
والافارقه بحكم موقعه تاريخي
نحن دوما نسعى لان تظل اثيوبيا موحده
اثيوبيا قويه وهم يبادلون هذا الشعور ايضا
يريدون ان يرص ودان ايضا واحدا قويا يعبر
الى مصاف او الى تحقيق امنيات شعبه نحنا
بنحييهم ان احنا اتفقنا في كل الامور كل
ما نقشناه من امر لم نجد اي اختلاف او اي
اختلاف في اي من امورنا وهي كلها نريدها
ان تصب في مصلحه الشعبين لتقويه هذه
العلاقه بين الدولتين الجارتين الشقيقتين